bien sécurisé sa maison c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement important et
aujourd'hui je vous présenter une
solution sécurité complète pour la
maison c'est un pack un pack intéressant
c'est toujours d'une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec Arlo pour
vous présenter ce pack là qui est
disponible chez Boulanger objet connecté
avec des caméras de Arlo pour venir
sécuriser votre maison et ça croyez-moi
c'est extrêmement important
on va pas y aller par quatre chemins je
vais vous montrer le pack regardez PAF
tout se passe ici alors vous avez un
pack avec différents produits de Harlow
je vous montre il vous le marque ici un
jeu sécurise ma maison et mon jardin
sans fil ils ont raison il faut le faire
il faut vraiment venir le faire et vous
avez différents produits qui vont être
inclus ici directement à l'intérieur
alors regardez vous allez avoir trois
caméras Arlo essential sont celles là en
fait ces caméras là alors caméra super
intéressante parce que si vous regardez
les Arlo essentiels c'est juste ça
caméra qui va être full HD on va filmer
en 1080p on a un angle de vue de 130
degrés il vous le marque sirène intégré
80 décibels histoire de faire fuir le
visiteur qu'on a pas souhaité avoir
détection de mouvement ça c'est aussi
vachement cool éclairage intégré et vous
pouvez venir parler directement donc ça
c'est bien vous en avez trois dans ce
pack là très cool comme ça vous allez
pouvoir venir les disposer à l'intérieur
de votre maison mais également à
l'extérieur parce qu'elles ne craignent
pas vous avez une autre caméra qui est
hyper canon c'est celle-là c'est la flou
de Light alors la Food light vous avez
une Arlo Pro 3 Floodlight avec une
batterie rechargeable étendue un câble
d'alimentation
micro USB qui de montage et CSA et
surtout la Food light elle est très très
cool pourquoi parce qu'elle vient en
complément de l'Arlot et sanchial
essential on peut le dire comme ça déjà
vous allez bien filmer avec une
résolution plus haute on filme en deux
cas ici vous avez un angle de vision de
160 degrés toujours une sirène à 90B
détection mouvement vous filmez deux
jours et de nuit ça c'est très bien et
puis vous avez un éclairage puissant qui
va jusqu'à 3000 Lumens jusqu'à je vais
vous expliquer j'ai tout vous montrer
donc aujourd'hui on va faire ça et puis
on va regarder parce qu'il y a un truc
qui est intéressant en plus avec le pack
vous avez trois mois décès gratuit de
Arlo Smart c'est la solution dans le
Cloud pour venir stocker vos fichiers
c'est très intéressant on va regarder ça
on va s'ouvrir ce pack et s'il vous
intéresse vous invite à faire un truc ça
cliquez sur le lien en bas dans la
description si vous voulez la voir pour
venir sécuriser votre maison vous allez
pas être déçu alors on s'ouvre ça petit
unboxing ensuite je vais aller faire une
install je vous montre ça vous allez
voir comment ça marche c'est super cool
alors on prend on ouvre attention tac
ouverture première boîte ouverture
deuxième boîte ça on peut l'enlever
alors première boîte c'est celle qu'on
va voir ici c'est effectivement les
Arnauds essential on arrache et vous
explique tout et ces trucs qui est
vraiment intéressant je vais vous
montrer vous pilotez tout directement
avec votre smartphone on va commencer
par enlever ça ok
on va ouvrir faites une caméra qui est
100% sans fil vous venez la connecter
directement à votre Wi-Fi pas besoin
d'avoir vous le configurer très
facilement et ça c'est cool regardez
trois caméras à l'intérieur on prend une
hop on prend on enlève donc sur chaque
caméra on va voir un petit pas de vis à
l'arrière la si on souhaite on a un
bouton pour venir l'allumer ici on peut
venir la recharger vous voyez ici ça
c'est du micro USB et vous avez votre
petite caméra avec le micro là ok très
pratique alors cette caméra là il y a
plusieurs bénéfices déjà elle est
résistante aux intempéries donc vous
pouvez la mettre à l'extérieur et bien
évidemment à l'intérieur vision nocturne
installation facile 6 mois de batterie
une surveillance ininterrompue et s'il
se passe quoi que ce soit et bien vous
recevrez une notification sur votre
smartphone et vous pouvez venir
l'associer avec un abonnement Arlo
secure comme ça vous allez conserver les
fichiers ils vont être dans le Cloud
c'est pratique et je vous explique ça
dans quelques instants c'est une
solution de surveillance qui va être
alimentée par l'intelligence
artificielle et qui va venir identifier
les menaces donc ça c'est la première et
dans ce pack vous en avez effectivement
trois alors
trois flots de Light caméra alors que ce
soit sur le New sur l'autre il y a un
truc qui est super intéressant je vous
montre si vous êtes vraiment technophile
vous pouvez aller loin bien évidemment
alors je vous l'ai dit à iOS Android on
l'a vu également Amazon Alexa pour venir
commander avec Alexa mais également
Google assistant et en plus ça travaille
avec ifttt alors si vous connaissez pas
ifttt c'est vraiment une solution à
venir découvrir qui vous permettra de
faire à peu près tout ce que vous voulez
chez vous pour me dire connecter les
objets entre eux je vous laisse regarder
parce que ça mériterait une vidéo très
complète à elle-même pour vous parlertt
alors faites voir la caméra en elle-même
hop là on prend lourd yes waouh on
dirait presque à rétroviseur de bagnole
tellement ce truc est grand ça c'est
hyper chouette la solution elle est
complète comme ça alors attendez on va
regarder pour enlever tous les
plastiques là je vais vous dire qu'ils
ont mis la quantité pour venir protéger
votre caméra et vous avez un petit film
à l'avant aussi ça c'est une caméra qui
fait pas pareil parce qu'en fait vous
avez une caméra et vous avez ici tout un
dispositif lumineux c'est de la LED vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à 3000 Lumens si
vous le branchez directement sur le
secteur sinon sur batterie vous montez
jusqu'à 2000 lumens et ça c'est bien
parce que ça va venir réellement
éclairer déjà vous avez imaginé un truc
qui arrive chez vous si je prends la
lumière en plein de tronc j'ai dit waouh
waouh qu'est-ce qui se passe et en plus
c'est pareil vous avez une sirène à 80
décibels autant vous dire qu'ici ça va
s'entendre elle est directement
installée sur le support pareil le
support c'est articulé vous venez le
mettre comme vous voulez vous voyez très
facilement c'est cool ensuite à
l'intérieur de la boîte qu'est-ce que je
vais retrouver donc là j'ai un petit
bloc secteur ça c'est le USB ah ça c'est
pour l'adaptateur ok là j'ai du micro
USB USB a ok ça c'est quoi
c'est la batterie ça on a ensuite petit
support pour venir l'installer avec
visse et cheville ok de la même manière
des notices ça vous le prenez vous venez
l'insérer dedans comme ça vous le mettez
sur le secteur en France j'ai la même
chose si je veux aller ça c'est au
Royaume-Uni ok bon voilà mais on est en
France donc pas besoin de ça et ensuite
je crois qu'on a fait le tour j'ai
pareil un petit manuel des informations
qui vont m'expliquer comment venir à
l'installer et si je veux vraiment venir
informer les cambrioleurs regarder je
leur mets ça à la protective Arlo Smart
Security on n'est pas là pour se marrer
ça c'est bien parce qu'il vous explique
vraiment comment bien le configurer très
très facilement vous avez la batterie à
l'intérieur vous venez l'ouvrir en fait
bouton d'accès à la batterie donc là
j'ai mon bouton qui situe juste là
j'appuie hop ça ouvre je viens mettre ma
batterie qui est là à l'intérieur elle
vient se positionner comme ça je prends
j'en mets je ferme s'éclipser vous voyez
juste le bouton là hop très facile et là
j'ai ma batterie qui est installé sur
tout le recharger ici là voyez en micro
USB pratique et après on vous explique
ce que vous avez à l'intérieur une fois
de plus on vous renvoie sur le site de
Arlo pour tout savoir en fait cette
caméra c'est un puissant bouclier de
lumière c'est la première caméra un
projecteur 100% sans fil au monde vous
allez illuminer jusqu'à 7 mètres vous
voyez un qu'avec ça ça en vrai imaginez
elle est quand même ici plus puissante
que les phares d'une voiture comme la
Arlo et sunshal vous allez la connecter
tout piloter grâce à votre smartphone
très facilement iOS Android une fois de
plus ici vous allez pouvoir filmer des
vidéos en direct en deux cas pour
déclencher à distance la sirène pour la
dissuasion si besoin elle est très
facile à installer et vous avez une
protection immédiate et une fois de plus
ici on a pas de fil et on se connecte
directement au wifi alors si vous voulez
venir zoomer on peut venir zoomer
jusqu'à x 12 pour venir identifier si
besoin des personnes sur les vidéos ici
on a un grand angle de 160 degrés autant
vous dire qu'elle va très très large
donc si vous voulez surveiller une très
grande superficie vous avez de quoi
faire on a en plus de ça une vision
nocturne en couleur des images claires
et précises vous pouvez en plus
communiquer en audio je vous vois vous
arrivez chez moi à porter s'il vous
plaît portez ou je mets la lumière et la
sirène et vous réglez tout directement
dans votre application la sensibilité la
lumière bref tout et en plus de ça et ça
c'est plutôt intéressant pour y venir
les combiner avec un panneau solaire
pour le rapporter de l'énergie en
permanence et ne pas avoir besoin de les
télécharger ça c'est aussi assez malin
alors ça c'est pour les caméras mais je
vous parlais il y a également un
abonnement que vous pouvez venir prendre
cher à l'eau qui va venir compléter la
gamme c'est Arlo secure Arlo secure ici
c'est vendu séparément et je vous l'ai
dit ici vous avez quand même trois mois
d'essai gratuit je vous recommande de
prendre l'abonnement pourquoi et bien
parce que vous allez venir stocker les
images dans le Cloud entre 30 et 60
jours ça va dépendre de votre abonnement
au moins vous êtes sûr que vous aurez
les images parce que si toutefois
quelqu'un arrivait à rentrer chez vous
moi vous aurez des vidéos à remettre en
forme de l'ordre comme je vous l'ai dit
si tout est piloté avec de
l'intelligence artificielle ils vont
faire en sorte que la caméra
identifie et hiérarchie des informations
identifier notamment des personnes des
voitures des objets un colis un animal
et en plus de ça ils ont fait un truc
qui est assez malin c'est que si vous
avez un voleur qui dit tiens il y a une
caméra je vais la ramasser je vais la
voler bah ouais peut-être qu'il pense
que tout est là-dedans arlo a une
protection contre le vol au niveau de
votre matériel pas de se cacher vous ce
qui fait qu'il vous remplaceront le
matériel qui a été volé et en plus de ça
il y a un truc qui vachement intéressant
au niveau de votre smartphone et je vous
montre une fois de plus dans quelques
instants vous avez un écran du rouillage
qui est breveté ici par Arlo c'est à
dire que vous aurez un aperçu vidéo des
alertes vous pourrez réagir très
facilement en déclenchant la sirène ou
en contactant en ami et tout ça sans
déverrouiller pas fun et une fois de
plus vous renvoie au lien dans la
description pour venir prendre le pack
Arlo boulanger pour venir configurer
c'est facile vous venez ajouter un
nouvel appareil on se parle bien ici de
caméra là c'est la Arlo essential
celle-là on la reconnaît bien ici
accéder aux paramètres de téléphone
Wi-Fi connectez-vous réseau 2,4
identifiant du wi-fi le réseau appuyez
sur le bouton 5 mettre le enfoncé
pendant une à deux secondes voilà j'ai
la lumière bleue qui est juste là
continuez maintenez le QR code en face
de votre caméra ok recherche de votre
caméra Arlo caméra Arlo trouver donner
un nom à votre caméra Arlo on va
l'appeler caméra 1 fuseau horaire
recherche de mise à jour la mise à jour
est terminée positionnez votre caméra
Arlo bande passante fort trouver un
emplacement ok bon je vais le faire
votre caméra Arlo est à présent actif
terminé donc là j'ai ma version d'essai
hop je peux commencer et vous voyez là
j'ai la caméra à la main je viens de
filmer et je peux voir exactement ce qui
se passe en direct et je fais exactement
la même chose pour configurer les trois
autres caméras une fois qu'on a fait une
installer ces caméras on retrouve tout
ici dans son application vous voyez
l'installation est très facile ici je
l'ai installé un peu dans la végétation
mais elle est très discrète comme ça ça
permet d'avoir un plan large sur le
jardin on peut venir me voir comme ça
très facilement ça c'est vachement bien
et la nuit vous aurez la lumière et si
vous le souhaitez pour venir l'activer
vous directement c'est très bien
[Musique]
vous avez vos différentes caméras dans
votre application avec les dernières
scènes les derniers moments où vous avez
ici et vous pouvez voir le direct
comment battre par exemple floodlite
voyons on est sur le direct je peux
venir actionner ici si je le souhaite
l'éclairage je peux venir régler
l'intensité je peux venir l'arrêter je
peux venir tout paramétrer ici
directement dans mon application c'est
extrêmement complet et très facile
d'utilisation je vous invite une fois de
plus à dire découvrir le pack Arlo qui
est disponible chez Boulanger je vous
mets le lien en bas dans la description
allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil parce
que vous allez voir c'est une solution
très simple d'utilisation très facile à
configurer et extrêmement complète pour
la maison une fois de plus le lien est
en bas dans la description c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]